quand il ya la pleine lune plus
généralement les fous sont sortis des
bandes qui se bagarre sur fond d'alcool
des entraînements plus que musclée
[Musique]
ils font face à toutes les difficultés
de jour comme de nuit il veille sur la
population
ce sont les anges gardiens du nord ces
policiers vous invite à partager sans
fard la réalité de leur quotidien
des proches ont offert en général de
l'héroïne leur combat contre la
délinquance sur fond de violence
ordinaire et de misère sociale
d'accord on est content dehors du cube
bienvenue dans les coulisses du
commissariat central de lille lundi plus
actives de france
[Musique]
nous sommes au sud de l'île cette
austère bâtiment en béton surmontée
d'une antenne abrite le centre
névralgique du commissariat la police
secours bonjour nous sommes au cic le
centre d'information et de commandement
un service ultra moderne divisé en deux
salles dans la première on réceptionne
les appels du 17 pour tout le
département nord pas de calais une
dizaine de policiers se relaient 24
heures sur 24 à l'ecoute des 2200 appels
quotidiens le 17 police secours bongeot
le 17 est normalement réservé
exclusivement aux urgences mais en
réalité les gens appellent pour tours et
n'importe quoi
nous allons bon jour là je ne pas même
nappe est pas un renseignement ont très
peu de l'autre il ya le parking et le
club en public
fouad qui travaillent ici depuis deux
ans en sait quelque chose
vous regardez sur l'annuaire madame 1
vous c'est le 17 police secours on
traite les gens si c'est vraiment le
voilà donc on n'est pas une plateforme
de renseignement difficile de faire
admettre à certains interlocuteurs
qu'ils engorger inutilement le 17
seulement 12% des appels reçus ici
nécessite une vraie urgence de police sa
position cours on joue comme par exemple
cet appel d'un directeur de banque qui
craint un hold up lors d'attention c'est
quoi comme véhicule
je verrai fuad reconnais cette fois une
véritable urgence qu'il s'empresse de
signaler à l'opérateur radio dans
l'autre pièce si ces quatre individus
sont dans une logan
c'est depuis cette salle de commandement
que les opérateurs passe les appels
radio aux équipes de police secours sur
le terrain
cette affaire est prise au sérieux donc
on a un véhicule logan est stationné
depuis que dix minutes 1 sur le
l'emplacement convoyeur de fonds n'a pas
manqué son annonce parvient directement
un véhicule radio localisés dont on peut
suivre tous les déplacements sur cette
carte
à son bord la brigade de jours ps en
rose alpha qui reçoit l'info cinq sur
cinq
ce serait bizarre de ré quatre individus
à bord avec des bonnets donc si vous
pouvez vous rapprocher pour ce véhicule
et ces individus suspects également et
c'est parti l'équipe de robert fonte
aussitôt vers le lieu de sa mission des
interventions de police secours il y en
a environ 500 par jour à lille
[Musique]
arrivés sur place les policiers
encerclent le véhicule suspect le
conducteur
mais ils s'aperçoivent rapidement qu'il
s'agit d'une fausse alerte
et voilà cette voiture garée au mauvais
endroit pour une simple pause café a
mobilisé toute une escouade de policiers
mais pas le temps de se lamenter sur ce
pétard mouillé
l'équipe enchaîne directement sur une
histoire plus sérieuse de faux billets
le gérant d'un supermarché vient
d'appeler cette personne bonjour j'ai dû
prendre transparence apparemment la
copie n'est pas terrible et les
policiers n'ont aucun mal à distinguer
le vrai du faux billets de banque
vous avez une autre vie l'homme n'a sur
lui qu'un seul faux billets de 100 euros
mais cela suffit pour éveiller les
soupçons des policiers ils veulent payer
faux mais où est-ce que tu l'a oublié ça
oui moi travailler on est allé et non en
italie ça fait 20 ans que j'étais en
france le jeu arrive aujourd'hui avec
son bateau rose - soit arrivé seulement
aidé son bateau il seulement les pros
téléphone portable la carabine et il a
refusé d'y prendre part au téléphone en
plus y'a plein de plus le mans
pour robert ces signes sont suspects ok
bon le carnet gelés ils croient déceler
que l'homme lui cache quelque chose
les policiers décident donc de le
ramener au commissariat pour poursuivre
leur interrogatoire
mais la communication est difficile car
l'homme est italien et il parle très mal
le français
what is honey leur faveur et speak
english
l'homme ne parle pas plus anglais ou
allemand heureusement les policiers
peuvent appeler à la rescousse un de
leurs collègues qui lui parle italien
mais il n'obtiendra pas grand chose de
plus tu habites ou en italie je suis
venu ici pour chercher du travail
c'est quoi ton numéro en numéro en
france je me rappelle plus
le suspect n'est pas franchement bavard
mais ils parviennent au moins à lui
faire remplir sa fiche d'interpellation
il sera finalement placé en garde à vue
pour la brigade ps en onze alpha la
journée maintenant terminée 21h c'est
l'heure de la prise de poste pour la
vacation de nuit à police secours
jérémy à 30 ans ce soir ils et de
services il rejoint les autres équipages
réunis autour du major pour l'appel oui
bonsoir à tous donc chef de poste
bp consulat et rémy si tu peux faire des
passages cette nuit pour une robe de
viande dynamique en cardio assis à côté
de jérémy c'est xavier son coéquipier
cela fait onze ans qu'il travaille dans
les brigades de nuit pour ce soit 7 ps
c'est-à-dire cette équipe de police
secours qui vont quadriller la ville
jusqu'à 5 heures du matin bon on va
écouter rien à dire bonne soirée à tous
et bon courage
la mission de police secours
c'est d'assurer la sécurité des biens et
des personnes de protéger les habitants
les secteurs sont attribués xavier
jérémy peuvent commencer leur patrouille
nocturne
c'est la pleine lune on va avoir du
boulot
bah c'est véridique un quartier à la
pleine lune plus généralement les fous
sont sortis
il
matt n 59 bonsoir à tous privé coûte de
la paix ce sens delta à bord du car
immatriculé un peu de temps avant sa
saison et je verrai aussi au flat
octobre avance aux effectifs de
fonctionnaires horaires théoriques 21h05
heure 10 pour info on a deux
journalistes à bord et non des muni d'un
éthylotest reçu la première mission du
soi vient juste de tomber
direction un grand magasin en plein
centre ville
deux mineurs de 17 ans aurait volé
quatre bouteilles d'alcool de luxe pour
une valeur de 200 euros
bien que très jeune le garçon est déjà
connaisseurs il est désormais seul car
son complice présumé
prétextant une envie pressante est
parvenu à s'enfuir
craignant qu'il ne se sauve à son tour
jérémy préfère prendre ses précautions
vous laisse le jeune homme n'avait pas
prévu ça mais il passera la nuit au
commissariat
ce jeune garçon n'en est pas à son coup
d'essai
mais faut calmer à 17 ans il est déjà
bien connu des services de police le
jeune homme prétend qu'à présent il a
trouvé du travail pour gagner de
l'argent honnêtement ce que j'ai arrêté
les camry il avoue cependant avoir été
dealer à ses heures ce qui lui
rapportait beaucoup plus que son job sur
les marchés au moins 1000 euros par jour
achète une plaquette la coupole en
détail sur entier touré cas de moscou un
peu tout on ne peut pas la pression
puisqu'ils rapport la routine quoi
pourtant il laisse entendre qu'il
aimerait bien changer de vie
et puis quand on est jeune et marié des
enfants sans emploi soit lyonnais se
rendre compte à 50 ans ils ne sentent
contemporain il y en a donc pas du tout
dans l'est dans l'église la rue va dire
chez entre les deux m'ont appuyé dans le
monde entier donnent des ailes pour
essayer de s'en sortir
le garçon avait intégré une école de
coiffure l'an dernier poursuivi par ses
démons il a abandonné après avoir été
placés en centres d'éducation renforcés
suite à une accumulation de délits le
centre d'éducation renforcée c'est la
dernière alternative avant la prison
pour les mineurs
au cours de la procédure
d'interpellation
les policiers découvrent que le garçon
est déjà convoqué au tribunal
c'est le service départemental de nuit
qui prend la décision de mettre ou non
les interpellés en garde à vue jérémy
vient faire son rapport aux brigadiers
de permanence qui ramène aux mineurs
interpellés pour vol à l'étalagé web on
va le placer en garde à vue comanche le
brigadier vient de confirmer la garde à
vue du jeune homme
[Musique]
garde à vue louis lejeune est à présent
sous la responsabilité du sdn après sa
nuit au poste
il sera remis à ses parents en attendant
sa convocation devant le juge comme
après chaque interpellation
jérémy doit encore taper le procès
verbal cette paperasse quotidienne
n'entame pas sa passion pour son métier
quand il est entré dans la police en
2001 il était l'un des plus jeunes flics
de france
j'ai passé le concours c'est dans en
fait on peut passer le concours à partir
de 7 ans et le jour de mes 17 ans
j'étais au commissariat de béthune
chercher un dossier d'inscription
pourtant j'ai pas de gêne pas de famille
dans la police on met ça en fait j'avais
j'ai mon meilleur ami son père était
fonctionnaire de police
et puis bon il marche il est une part
fils un peu la fibre quand il nous
racontait à son fils à moi ces
interventions passées et puis ça nous a
donné l'envié de faire le versement au
budget et à qui ceci le fils il sait
déjà par ici il est chauffeur routier
main
22h il est encore tôt les deux
coéquipiers repartent pour une première
reconnaissance des deux rues les plus
chaudes du centre ville histoire d'en
mesurer l'ambiance c'est ici que les
étudiants bien se retrouver pour faire
la fête
donc vous aussi les rue de la soif c'est
la concentration tous les bassins sur
votre boss de solférino c'est la grande
ligne droite donc c'est quasiment barque
sorba c'est assez calme mais bon ca
prévu de changer ses rues ne s'anime
qu'à partir de minuit
car avant de sortir en boîte ou dans les
bars les jeunes commence presque
toujours leur soirée par une petite fête
chez eux et la plupart du temps ils font
trop de bruit
résultat les voisins appellent le 17
pour se plaindre du tapage nocturne
[Musique]
bonsoir et allocataires locataire des
lieux peut sortir avec une fille
on sort notre locataire des lieux si on
revient ce qu'on nous a appelés et sont
régulièrement voir que j'aurais signé
tout de suite
mais le souci c'est que maintenant les
gens ils viennent plus forcément voir
dérange pour rien des amis vous êtes
combien la période on est jeudi l'elysée
on fait rien vu
le tri qui a même pas de son joug diffa
loyer vendredi des gens qui travaillent
de vous baisser le bruit on en reste là
c'est un avertissement verbal
voilà vous avez versé aux messieurs est
ce que ça vous dit pas tout en tout cas
qu'on soit pas rappelé non mais non pour
le moment xavier jérémy font preuve
d'une certaine indulgence
bon là je pense que ils ont compris
puisqu'ils l'ont pas compris et on est
si on est rappelé mon lait verbalisant
pour un tapage nocturne
les gens croient qu'à partir de 22
heures on doit plus faire de bruit mais
c'est pas vrai en fait il n'ya pas il
n'y a pas d'heure légales pour faire ou
ne pas faire du bruit ce qui a le souci
c'est que les gens n'osent plus aller
voir les voisins pour dire de à mon avis
a déjà eu des cas où bat le
le voisin qui venait gentiment demandé
de baisser la musique alors partait de
là avec un coup de poing ou un coup de
pied et puis ça partait sur des
violences donc maintenant je pense que
les gens ne prennent plus de risques et
puis préfère nous appeler pour que pour
qu'on intervienne pas
cela fait un peu plus de quatre ans que
jérémy a intégré les brigades de nuit à
police secours les policiers qui
travaillent la nuit ne touche qu'une
centaine d'euros de plus par mois par
rapport au service de jour mais ce n'est
visiblement pas l'argent qui les motive
au niveau des horaires quand on a
quand on a des enfants à s'occuper c'est
appréciable
on a toutes nos après midis après au
niveau du boulot c'est vraiment un monde
à part comme
c'est pas une légende que le monde de la
nuit c'est vraiment c'est vraiment autre
chose et la nuit on est toujours
interviennent toujours en zone rouge
c'est à dire qu'on se méfier plus on se
méfie puisqu'on journée à cause du
danger sur le coup quand vous avez une
intervention assez palpitant qui à
l'adrénaline qui qui rentre en compte et
je pense que en fait on on s'en rend
compte une fois l'intervention terminée
l'adrénaline il la trouve souvent aux
fins de nuit dans ce qu'on appelle les
rue de la soif
les jeunes sont alors très alcoolisé et
prêts à se bagarrer pour un oui ou pour
un non
[Musique]
4 heures du matin un jeune homme vient
se plaindre aux policiers on lui cherche
des noises depuis le début de la soirée
voilà fera bien en boite je suis en
hermine forcément il m'attend là depuis
tout à l'heure dix films aux textes ils
envoient beaucoup de temps après la voie
publique est à tout le monde je peux pas
l'empêcher de après si vous êtes
apprécié vous dérangera changeait pas
ce qui me dérange c'est est partout
selon m vous aviez jérémy décide
d'intervenir
histoire de calmer le jeu et d'éviter
que ça ne tourne en bagarre
un problème comme des frères chefs
d'après le problème c'est une histoire d
un peu la bande fait mine d'être
réconciliés
mais à peine les policiers ont-ils
tourné le dos
mais attention ça va repartir savoir
partir qu'ils recommencent à se battre
voilà ce démarrer
les policiers décident alors
d'intervenir à nouveau bon vous allez
jouer longtemps comme ça ou quoi un oh
ouais ouais
par prudence jérémy garde sa bombe de
gaz lacrymogène à la main bah ouais mais
à chaque fois ça depuis un quart d'heure
ça dure on nous a dit ok si tes copains
ils savent quoi barba faut partir à faut
pas rester là si on veut on peut jouer
20 minutes une demi heure avec eux en
fait c'est le jeu du chat et la souris
il vole c'est mieux éviter pour battre
ailleurs et puis bah quand tu nous vois
arriver tout ce folklore fait partie de
la vie nocturne lilloise
la présence policière refroidi les
esprits elle est dissuasive
il rassure aussi les gens qui viennent
vraiment ici pour s'amuser
[Musique]
c'est l'heure du retour au commissariat
il est 5 heures 10 l'anus termine juste
avant de rentrer dernier arrêt devant
cette rôtisserie ambulante ouverte au
petit matin
mais ce n'est pas pour acheter un poulet
grillé bonjour ça va et vous bah ouais
on fait de la pub pour votre commerce
[Rires]
et pourquoi donc fier de l'appui pour
ces messieurs un peu racoleur vend des
poulets donc on lui dit bonjour par rien
de tel qu'une bonne petite blague pour
clore une longue nuit de travail
[Musique]
8 heures du matin une nouvelle journée
commence au commissariat central de
lille dans la salle de sport mise à la
disposition des policiers
christophe vient s'entraîner dès qu'il
en a l'occasion
il reste 37 tourner à deux minutes et
demie depuis sept ans il est formateur
en techniques d'intervention pour lui
maintenir une forme physique parfaite
est indispensable c'est important
surtout par rapport à l'image qu'on
donne
à quarante minutes a une belle allure on
n'a plus envie d'aller vers lui et bien
ça aussi je pense impose le respect oui
christophe a deux beaux muscles mais
s'il inspire le respect à ses collègues
c'est surtout pour ses compétences il a
passé 14 ans au gipn le groupe
d'intervention de la police nationale
mais en fait on est terrifié on
l'attendait sur le forcené
sur les assistances type 6 heures du
matin c'est à dire aller chercher les
dealers de drogue des violeurs etc etc
et ensuite on était habilité à faire
aussi les mutineries dans les prisons et
les protections de personnalités
christophe est maintenant attendu par
une dizaine de policiers au stand de tir
attention ici les conditions de sécurité
sont très strictes
il faut un ballon ce matin il supervise
une séance d'entraînement avec tony un
autre formateur
je suis ici je dévorais loin mon marteau
à labatut d'accord ça marche je me
relève jour posé le genou faire porter
position ok est-ce que c'est clair pour
tout le monde
ce n'est pas une banale séance de tir
les deux moniteurs ont préparé toute une
mise en scène pour que les policiers se
retrouvent au plus près des réalités du
terrain et avant de commencer à tirer
mises en situations obligatoires
ce jeune policier geoffroy commence par
un programme de diplôme hook et 20
flexion puis il doit courir en portant
un abri en bois à s'ils ont fait des
petits parcours de stress des petits
parcours d'endurance pour justement
faire monter les pulsations mettre dans
un état un petit peu qui se rapproche
d'un état de stress main à les
thématiques du coup au moment de tirer
geoffroy est aussi essoufflé que s'il
poursuivait réellement un malfaiteur
dans la rue
le montant
geoffroy se montre un très bon tireur il
doit juste corriger un petit défaut ou
sur double très bien sorti d'harmonica
elle par contre tu en vois ta 1ère et la
2ème juste des peut-être une seconde ça
doit faire
pas d'accord une ode à bolt à chaque
fois ok c'est bien c'est un super tir
d'anton tire là ici de réaction à ce qu
il ya des moments où tu fermes à neuilly
sa mère
il faudrait c'est aussi pour ça que
c'est un peu parasites
si tu prends du temps pour fermer un
oeil temps de beule top ça va faire bon
bon alors que si tu prends pas ce temps
pour fermer un oeil et tu sois plus
concentré sur temps sur ton action tir à
ce moment là tu vas être beaucoup plus
rapide
les policiers doivent faire au moins
trois séances comme celle ci chaque
année c'est obligatoire larmes qui
l'utilisent c'est le 6e joueur qui tire
des balles de 9 mm donc le policier
lorsqu'il arrive dans la police à son
arme individuelle la garde toute sa
carrière
c'est numérotés et un numéro de série ça
évite déjà les échanges les pertes en
plus le fonctionnaire responsable de son
armée de son entretien forcément voilà
pour préventive vous avez après la
séance de tirs tous les tous les
collègues qui nettoient leurs armes
de plus toutes les armes sont révisés
chaque année par les armuriers
merci plaisir
[Musique]
loin du centre historique de lille
de l'autre côté de la ville se trouvent
les quartiers récemment classées zones
de sécurité prioritaire des quartiers
qui concentre bien des maux recrutement
de bandes vols de voitures circulation
d'armes et surtout trafic de drogue
cette petite antenne de police dépend
elle aussi du commissariat central situé
en plein coeur de la zone sensible à
lille sud est la brique la bst la
brigade spécialisée de terrain
cela fait 20 ans qu'olivier en fait
partie et qu'ils patrouillent dans les
rues pour traquer toutes formes de
délinquance le camp romain g il est là
pour débuter la journée visite dans le
gigantesque camp de roms illicites
implanté en pleine ville sur un terrain
privé un bidonville de trois hectares où
habite 600 personnes venues de roumanie
2 slovaquie et de bulgarie l'un des
problèmes récurrents dans cette cour des
miracles c'est que pour survivre
certains ici volera des câbles en cuivre
doit s'assurer qu'il n'ya pas du câble
qui proviendraient de la sncf on a
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de vols de
métaux des feux batiche confondre le
cuivre et les lots 6 6 e 8 euros il
fonde sa fille après il rend fort grâce
à des ferrailleurs peu scrupuleux
qu'est-ce que vous tuez travel a donc
fait crever des trucs olivier vient de
repérer un feu bien à l'abri des regards
sous ces hangars ça va comme vous voulez
la voilà donc là on fait fondre de du
cuivre pour revendre le câble volée ils
doivent d'abord brûler la gaine en
plastique qui l'entourent et ce feu
dégagent des gaz toxiques
en relève toi tu vas prendre feu là
parfois ces méthodes déclenché des
incendies extrêmement grave
là les policiers viennent de surprendre
ses hommes en flagrant délit mais
problème comme c'est ce sera pas
possible de savoir d'où ça vient
on peut faire contenir du recel sur
trois bouts de cuivre malheureusement en
feuilletant salah est un est un tout de
suite les quantités de méthane brûlé
aujourd'hui sont insuffisantes et faute
de preuves sur leur provenance
les policiers doivent en rester là après
avoir fait éteindre le feu mais ils ne
font pas chou blanc à chaque fois
pas plus tard que la semaine dernière là
on a ramassé propres et combien de kilos
centaines de kilos sa présence le cuivre
volé ce n'est pas ce qui mobilise le
plus la bst l'essentiel de sa mission
c'est la lutte contre le trafic de
drogue principalement de l'héroïne et du
cannabis
une économie parallèle florissante qui
se développe ouvertement même en plein
jour au pied de ces immeubles
donc en fait là c'est un endroit où les
toxicomanes viennent consommer à l'abri
des regards
on voit des pochons petit pochon vide
qui ont fait en général de l'héroïne
on en trouve tout le long du bâtiment
le trafic de drogue et le fléau des
quartiers
et le moment idéal pour déloger les
toxicos et les dealers du coin c'est
surtout quand la nuit est tombée
le soir ça prend plus belle puisque
forcément c'est plus facile à dissimuler
le soir que la journée donc trafic est
beaucoup plus important le soir olivier
connaît son secteur comme sa poche
il sait où aller chercher les deux
policiers viennent de repérer quelques
jeunes dans le hall de cet immeuble ils
les prennent en chasse impossible d'être
discrets car contrairement à la bac qui
travaillent en civil la bst est en tenue
alors quand elle arrive quelque part
elle est tout de suite repéré par les
bandes comme souvent aussi en fait il ya
trois quatre jeunes étaient dans vol
elle problème c'est qu'ils ont vu il y
en a qui s'est parée pour le cannabis a
aujourd'hui cela devient un exploit
d'arrêter les trafiquants car ils sont
de plus en plus malin
non non si c'est pareil avant d'entonner
des portes claquées maintenant les fonds
et ce n'est pas tout les dealers nargue
la police
grâce à des techniques de surveillance
très au point par exemple à cet étage ou
pour notre sécurité on nous demande de
tournées en caméra cachée les guetteurs
ont cassé cette fenêtre pour se créer un
poste d'observation idéal sacré et à la
montée puisque jésus la porte
oui le problème c'est cloud pour les
gens qui habitent ici à supportable de
rentrer chez soi et de d'enjamber les
jeunes qui sont en train de
les crachats
[Musique]
le rôle de la bst
c'est un peu de trac et l'intra câble
même s'il perd souvent la partie contre
les trafiquants olivier ne se décourage
pas fait 20 ans que je fais ça donc jour
j'en ai marre je me mettrai dans un
bureau et pour l'instant ça me plaît la
bst est une brigade de proximité qui
n'hésite pas à aller partout pour
assainir les zones de non-droit et
maintenir la paix dans les quartiers
une autre unité spécialisée est ami
arrêter les trafiquants chez eux
ces sommes doivent garder l'anonymat
quand ils sont en mission ils sont
toujours cagoulés ce sont des policiers
chevronnés
rattaché à la brigade de sûreté
départementale la bsd il travaille sur
des enquêtes au long cours qui se
terminent parfois par des
interpellations musclées sur le terrain
aujourd'hui banon on travaille beaucoup
sur les home jacking les équipes de home
jacking un cambriolage vol à main armée
trafic de stups aujourd'hui majorité des
gens ont la possibilité d'avoir une arme
chez eux donc on préfère pallier à toute
situation
aujourd'hui ils suivent une formation
avec christophe la brigade compte sur
l'expérience de cet ancien du gipn pour
perfectionner les techniques
d'intervention hockey bonjour messieurs
bonjour à tous donc aujourd'hui on va
faire un stage boucliers balistiques
souple avec les progressions en milieu
confiné donc vous allez évolue
essentiellement dans des appartements
donc on va aller chercher à chaque fois
des gens dans des appartements hockey
l'équipement est ultra lourd il ya les
matraques
ce bélier à vérins qui peut exercer
jusqu'à 7 tonne de pression pour
enfoncer les portes sans compter le
casque avec visière pare balles de 3 cm
d'épaisseur qui pèse à lui seul plus de
3 kg
de plus des bébés s il vous plait et en
plus les hommes portent les bbs ses
boucliers pliable qui protège
efficacement des balles mais qui sont
encombrants au cours d'un assaut ils
doivent apprendre à se déplacer avec
c'est quand vous voulez attention c'est
comme au cinéma
l'action se passe dans cet immeuble
désaffecté
l'idée c'est de déloger un truand reclus
chez lui christophe a prévu plusieurs
scénarios de plus en plus complexes
il joue lui-même un rôle dans ces mini
fiction se transforme en d'abord en
dealer de drogue
planqué dans sa salle de bain pour finir
il devient un forcené russe qui menace
de tirer sur les policiers
parce qu'il ne veut pas finir en prison
et on dira mme interpellé et là je vais
résister un petit peu non non on vient
me chercher
si je pose mon âme je vais devoir
d'abord donc tu rentres dans la pièce je
recule de la porte
tu peut l'ouvrir si je la poste je me
promets de rien faire tu veux tu veux je
la pose ou allons alors moi je m'allonge
pas
[Musique]
franchement on s'y croirait non cette
opra et voilà opération terminée ennemis
maîtriser ça va moi j'ai une tenue bleue
très impressionnant même si on sait que
tout ça c'était pour de faux côté police
secours
xavier jérémy entament leur deuxième
nuit consécutive
[Musique]
pas le temps de dire ouf c'est déjà
parti xavier traverse la ville pied au
plancher
[Musique]
pas les collègues bac ont pris en charge
un véhicule le véhicule apparemment il
sait il s'est planté à l'entrée de
l'autoroute donc on va aller 1
on va les sécuriser l'entrée de
l'autoroute c'est une bmw qui a été
repéré et poursuivi un peu plus tôt par
la brigade anticriminalité la bac à son
bord il y avait quatre jeunes leur
course poursuite s'est brutalement
terminée les opposeront power ip ici bas
comme c'est une propulsion et sa
patronne à conduire ils sont partir en
tête à queue ils ont percuté ils ont
fait souffrir
ils veulent jouer avec nous mais les
folies perdre le combat ils ont perdu la
petite bande a déjà eu des démêlés avec
la police
leur voiture n'est pas un véhicule volé
en revanche le chauffeur n'a pas le
permis de conduire
il est donc embarqué par la bac pour
passer la nuit en garde à vue le défaut
de permis est un déni il risque jusqu'à
deux ans de prison et une interdiction
de passer le permis
les trois autres occupants eux peuvent
rentrer chez eux
la police n'a rien à leur reprocher
quant à la voiture elle est enlevée le
soir même direction la fourrière
pour l'intervention suivante changement
d'univers radical accompagnant également
d'y vivre
c'est bien pris cette fois les policiers
sont dirigés vers l'un des quartiers les
plus défavorisés de lille
[Musique]
passé la porte d'entrée il règne une
odeur pestilentielle dans le couloir de
l'immeuble
c'est la locataire de l'appartement qui
a appelé le 17 mai c'est un homme qui
accueille xavier jérémy bonsoir
symbolise évoqué les peuples ou non
c'est pas moi c'est une excuse ou à les
parties comme tant elle est redescendue
c'était après son nouveau contrat et
partenaires son concubin elle est partie
une femme son ancien compagnon et son
nouveau conjoint
trois personnes qui auraient passé la
soirée ensemble dans cet appartement à
l'état de taudis xavier doit même
remonter son écharpe devant son nez pour
supporter la puanteur qui ont ici et on
ne sut qui si on met chez vous ici
je suis monsieur dégager les policiers
tentent de reconstituer ce puzzle sur
fond de misère sociale
mais il est difficile de comprendre le
récit incohérent de leurs interlocuteurs
l'urgence est maintenant de vérifier
s'il ya eu des violences ou non comme
quoi le bagarre ici ça s'est bagarré non
je sais pas s'il coûte ai je pas être
méchant avec m wen mais il ya un mais
toujours mais à saku quelles personnes
et dans un col
ça y est elles commencent les gars
simple ruisseau l'alcool
mots écoutez moi je vous cache pas moi
je bois de l'alcool mais j'suis
attention à votre consommation
d'accord mais elles des femmes bref ce
soir les policiers n'en apprendrons pas
plus à celle revient et puisqu'elle
encore rennes nous c'est toujours la
même histoire on découvre ici une autre
facette de leur métier un rôle
d'assistante sociale qu assume souvent
les équipes de police secours
bon malheureusement on s'y habitue et
quoi hein donc ça fait partie ça fait
partie du boulot genre le d'intervention
c'est vrai que c'est malheureux pour ces
personnes mais bon on va dire cour
s'attarde pas trop non plus sur sur leur
corps parce que sinon je pense que
lorsqu'on screens barricades
parce que aux nouvelles on devrait
prendre toute la misère du monde des
gens sur notre dos 2h30 du matin
certaines nuits les équipes font une
halte au commissariat juste le temps
d'un repas préparé par le chef de poste
grâce à une petite cagnotte à laquelle
tout le monde participe
menu du jour des frites et du cassoulet
pas très diététique mais effet anti
froid garantie le temps nous le permet
on se fait un petit plaisir entre
collègues pas toujours le cas au bassin
selon l'activité on est dépendant de
l'activité cadors une dernière frites
vite avalé car justement de l'activité
ce soir il y en a
vous aviez jérémy sont déjà repartis
pour une dernière ronde pour les rue de
la soif ils doivent gérer les
débordements des noctambules jusqu'à la
fermeture des boîtes de nuit des
débordements qui peuvent prêter à
sourire
sur le chemin du retour xavier remarques
tout à coup un jeune homme en train
d'uriner sur le mur d'une boutique nager
une balade et en même temps quoi
en même temps à un animal en même temps
en gare au bout de la route à des arbres
taboth d'habiter ou leader mais son
assurance vais finir par lui coûter cher
franchement ou 60 euros
le chercheur à réfléchir et surtout
apprendre par coeur ce petit extrait du
code pénal d'avoir commandé le cube en
famille noire deux emplacements au
podium
le jeune homme vient de prendre malgré
lui une leçon de civisme dont il se
souviendra sans doute longtemps
des ivrognes la nuit on ne retrouve
partout même sous les roues des voitures
qu'est ce qu'on disait sur l'alcool tout
à l'heure nous komment mais
contrairement aux précédents ces deux là
font sourire jérémie des jeunes qui
s'amusent ils ont un peu bu mais s'amuse
bon tant que ça reste bon enfant à notre
égard ils sont pas faits sont peu
provocateur et âme tout ça donc un bon
ok messieurs
cette fois c'est l'heure d'aller se
coucher pour de bon quand il ne
s'absentent pas plus de deux jours du
commissariat un policier a le droit
d'emporter son arme de service chez lui
par prudence vous aviez jérémy préfère
laisser la leur au placard pour la
vacation de nuit est terminée
dans le couloir il croise la relève
leurs collègues qui arrivent déjà pour
la prise de poste du matin
avec gamme
car au commissariat central de lille
on ne s'arrête jamais c'est une histoire
sans fin
[Musique]